great well thank you so much for uh
inviting me to give this talk
i'm going to tell you about some joint
work to appear with tan chen
robert huang who just spoke uh two talks
ago and jerry lee
and the subject of the talk is
exponential separations between learning
with and without quantum memory
so to begin with let's consider the
question
what is an experiment now this is
actually
a harder question than it may seem
because there are many different
protocols which fall
under the purview of experiments to list
some examples
we can consider measuring constants of
nature such as the speed of light or the
charge of an electron
we can consider quantifying dynamical
properties like the rate of a chemical
reaction
or inferring structural properties like
the symmetry group of crystal
or even many experiments attempt to
learn more abstract information
such as the chain of chemical reactions
that comprise photosynthesis
or whether yang mills describes the
strong force
this really emphasizes the question what
exactly is an experiment in its full
scope of generality
now there have been some recent
perspectives on this question
and some ways of thinking about it um
now one of them was advocated for
instance in this paper by huang kung and
preschool
earlier this year in which they
discussed how many experiments could be
thought of as quantum learning
algorithms
which learn properties of partially
uncharacterized systems
via examples another perspective
closely related which came out at around
the same time with
aharonov myself and she is that all
experiments are examples
of these protocols called quantum
algorithmic measurements
or abbreviated as qualms which are a
hybrid of black box algorithms and
interactive protocols
now these two different perspectives are
complementary to one another
and they build off of previous work on
quantum games and the quantum comb
formalism and so on that i don't have
time to review at the moment
but they offer a way of formalizing what
we mean by experiments in a way that
they're amenable to the techniques of
quantum information and quantum
computation namely
to to analyze experiments in a way
that we can think about their
computational complexity
so what i'm going to emphasize in this
talk is not the general story of what is
a quantum experiment but a particular
aspect of it
which is what is the power of quantum
memory in helping us
understand nature in particular as i as
it says here we like to quantify the
power
of a quantum memory in helping us learn
about nature view experiments
now we're going to consider two kinds of
experimental protocols which i will
explain in detail
the first is those with a classical
memory in which all of the information
from one round of the experiment to the
next is stored and manipulated on a
classical computer
this is very much in line with most
contemporary and certainly historical
experiments
and a newer possibility which is that
we have access to a quantum memory or
maybe a full-fledged quantum computer
on which we can store quantum data and
manipulate that quantum data using
quantum algorithms
so before proceeding further let me
elaborate on what i mean by
product experimental protocols with a
classical memory and those with a
quantum memory
so what do i mean by protocols with a
classical memory
well consider that we have three
subsystems we have nature which is the
system
that we would like to learn about we
have our lab system and we have our
classical memory
we can abstract a protocol with the
classical memory in the following way
so we have the lab in the classical
memory can only communicate classical
information
with one another now we're going to
consider a protocol in t
rounds and nature is going to be queried
once per round
what this means is that each round of
the experiment we get to have one
interaction between
our lab equipment and with nature now
maybe during that query
for instance nature may provide us with
a state that then we can measure that
each time we query nature it provides a
state
or perhaps when we interact with nature
when we query it it uh
it evolves our lab system with some
hamiltonian or some quantum channel
the point at least abstractly is that
each time that we query nature it has
some response it does something to the
lab system in return
now each round is built as follows first
we prepare a state on the lab system a
quantum state
where the state can depend adaptively on
the information that we've stored in the
classical memory
which is just classical information
then we query nature we set up an
interaction between nature and the lab
which
which changes the state of the lab in
some prescribed way
and then we measure the lab system with
the povm where our choice of povm can
depend adaptively on the classical
memory
and then we store the result namely the
index of the output of the plvm the
classical
the classical result and we we store
that in the quantum memory
so we don't get to store the outcome as
a quantum state we just get to know if
we measure povm
um what the classical outcome was
and then finally we initialize the lab
system to the all zero state
before proceeding to the next round as
such from round to round
the only information that persists from
round to round
is the classical information that is
stored in the classical memory
now in the quantum setting it looks very
similar except everything everywhere it
said classical is now replaced by the
word quantum
there can be quantum states and quantum
information which is stored in the
quantum memory
here of course we can prepare a state on
the lab which can depend adaptively on
the quantum membrane states that are
stored therein
we query nature as before in the second
step and then we can measure the lab
system with the povn which can depend
adaptively on the quantum memory
and we can store now the quantum outcome
in the memory
and then finally we can initialize the
lab system to the all zero state
but now here from round to round we have
an additional feature we can store
for example quantum states or uh
states that have been manipulated by
nature in the quantum memory from round
to round
so for instance if nature provides us
with a sample of a quantum state in each
round
if we do if we proceed and do an n
round protocol at the end the quantum
memory could potentially store
n copies of the state which nature has
provided
so our goal is to find tasks for which
there is an exponential advantage
using a quantum memory versus a
classical memory
in the sense which i just described now
there's two parts to such a goal
the first is to show that a task can be
done efficiently if we have access to a
quantum memory
and the second is to show that a task is
exponentially hard if we only have
access to a classical memory
now this first part is comparatively
easy all we have to do
is exhibit one efficient quantum
protocol namely a protocol with the
quantum memory which achieves the task
at hand
the harder part is the second part it's
difficult
in the case of a classical memory and to
show that we
to rule out all efficient protocols
using a classical memory
so proving hardness is uh via an
exponential lower bound is
the technically difficult part of this
goal
and we're going to focus in this talk in
particular
on this second part namely ruling out
all efficient protocols
in the presence of a classical memory
for certain experimental tasks
so there's been a lot of recent work in
this direction in the last year or so
some of which i would like to highlight
because it's particularly relevant for
what i'm going to tell you next
so last year there are some very
interesting results about exponential
separations
simultaneously in gate and query
complexity for learning properties of
classical oracles
for example in the context of
generalized simon's problem and the
welded tree problem
now earlier this year there was work by
huang kang preschool
about an exponential separation in query
complexity for learning pauli
observables
around the same time there's a paper by
myself uh aharonnath and she
about an exponential separation
simultaneously in gate and query
complexity
for learning properties of quantum
states and channels
now the work that i'm going to tell you
about today synthesizes
um the the the two papers which i just
told you by huang kong
preschool as well as by uh darit myself
and xiao yang
as well as another paper by bubek chen
and lee which was about mixedness
testing
and we're going to what we do is we
provide in this new work
a new framework for proving exponential
lower bounds for protocols with
classical memories
what this allows us to do is prove
exponential complexity
separations between interactive
protocols with and without quantum
memories
so let me outline the basic framework
of our techno of the basic technical
tool which we develop
and i'm going to outline it in a
particularly simple context
namely the context of of learning
states in this context we can imagine
that each time we query nature
nature provides us with a density matrix
rho it simply puts
a density matrix row into our lab system
that then we can make a povn measurement
on
we can also talk about more
sophisticated variations for example
where
nature for instance implements a quantum
channel on the lab
but we'll get to that later but in the
learning tree framework as i said
suppose we have a physical source namely
nature
which produces a state row upon being
queried and we want to learn about it in
a setting without a quantum memory
namely we would like to learn something
about the state row
now the basic protocol this is unpacking
what i told you
uh a few slides ago is that we obtain a
copy of row in the first round of the
experiment by querying nature
and then we measure it using in this
case a rank one povm
here are the projectors which build up
the povm bi where i is an index
and suppose that the output is q and we
store this in the classical memory
when i say the output is q what i mean
is that the povm which we would measure
would be b
sub q namely where i equals q so
q is the value of the classical index
now even though before i said
that we can do a general povn it
suffices
it's uh to consider the case of rank 1
povms
and so i'm going to consider this for
simplicity in our discussions here
now in the now this is the classical
outcome of the measurement
so in the next round we again obtain a
copy of row
and we measure using a rank one povm
where now this
rank one povm can be contingent it can
depend
on the classical outcome queue from the
previous round
so here i've taken the projectors which
builds up the rank one pov on
and i've indexed them by i but here
there's also a q index
indicating that it can depend adaptively
on the previous measurement outcome
now suppose that the output the of this
measurement is r
namely i equals r and then we can store
r in the classical memory for the next
round
and then we can repeat this for another
round obtain a copy of row uh measure
using a rank one pobm which can
which can depend on both previous
measurement outcomes q and r
and then we measure the value of the
classical index and so on and so forth
now there's a way of visualizing this
protocol in a way which is
makes it more visually transparent and
conceptually transparent what is going
on
so here is a picture of a learning tree
and here's how we should think about it
in the first round of the experiment
we measure a povm in this case a rank 1
povm
where each of the projectors so i've
written here b1 through bnot
which corresponds to these b's namely
it's the bs
which build up the projectors of the
rank 1 povm
so this this first part of the tree
these vertices here
represent the projectors of the rank 1
povm in the first round
now contingent on which one we measure
suppose we end up
finding we perform the measurement and
we obtain b2
in the first round then this prescribes
another set of another rank one povm
which depends on the classical
measurement outcome namely it depends on
this two index
so we have another povm b sub two one b
sub two two and so on
which is contingent or which depends on
the uh the classical outcome from the
previous round
this proceeds with further branchings of
the tree
in future rounds where uh whatever we
end up measuring suppose we end up
measuring b12
this then spawns below it we have then
a another part of the tree which is
which
gives the povm which we would do if we
had measured b sub 1 2.
so you can think about the tree as
building up an adaptive strategy
now this is now i want you to comment
that a particular instantiation of the
protocol
namely when you actually do the
experiment it corresponds
to a root to leaf path through the tree
that is
maybe it's in the first round you could
measure b2 in the second round you might
measure
b2 comma one and so on and so forth so
this is a particular path through the
tree
which which is a which will happen for
any particular instantiation of the
protocol when you make these
measurements and subsequent rounds
will correspond to a unique path through
the tree
now a tree of depth t corresponds to
measuring t copies of the state
each level of the tree we are measuring
one copy of row
and as such the depth of the tree
corresponds to the number
of copies of row that we measure in
totality throughout the entire protocol
so let's now take a step further
let's introduce some notation let v
naught through v t minus one
be the vertices corresponding to a root
to leaf path through the tree
here in this picture i labeled the
vertices by
states but now i'm going to index them
just abstractly by v naught through v t
minus 1
for a particular root to leave path
through the tree
now the probability of taking that path
if we are provided
in each round with the state row is
simply this product
here b sub vt this corresponds to the
the rank one projector of of the povm
at uh at level t which so this is the
rank one projector that lives at the
vertex v
sub t so if we take a product of this
over all t rounds t equals 0 to t minus
1 this is the probability
of a particular sequence of pov of
classical povm
outcomes that's indexed by these
vertices if the state row was provided
upon querying nature each time now
similarly if instead
sigma was the state that was provided
then well it would be the same formula
except that there would be a sigma in
place of the row
now if we would like to understand the
difficulty of a particular adaptive
strategy in telling the difference
between row and sigma
then what we should look at is the total
variational distance essentially the one
norm
of the difference between these two
probability distributions where we sum
over all all root-to-leaf paths through
the tree
now there's two basics proof strategies
which we employ in our in our work
one we call the edge-based strategy in
which we bound the information
a learner can gain from traversing any
edge in the tree
said more colloquially colloquially it's
the case that
we bound the amount of information that
an observer can learn in any particular
round of the protocol
there's another strategy which is we
call the path-based strategy
in which we bound the information gain
for traversing an entire path
namely an entire instantiation of the
protocol for all t rounds
not just bounding the information in
particular round
now to make this concrete let's consider
the setting of purity testing
so consider the following task suppose
we would like to
distinguish between on the one hand the
maxillary mixed state
and on the other hand a fixed har random
pure state
now a theorem from this paper with uh
dorit and xiao yang and myself
is that the query complex meaning the
number of states which are required
to achieve this task if you perform the
task for n qubits
namely maximum mixation and qubits and a
fixed random piercing and n qubits
is simply simply one a simply theta one
in particular what you do is you do a
swap test
now on the other hand the more
interesting case is the lower bound for
the case of a classical memory
in which we were able to establish an
exponential lower bound
namely you require exponentially many
copies of the state
in order to tell the difference between
a maximum mixed state and a fixed
random pure state i should also mention
of course that even though here we are
talking about query complexity
the complexity of the quantum protocol
is of course gate efficient
just order n if it's a swap test now
in this work just for for instance the
proof of the classical lower bound this
exponential lower bound
was quite a sophisticated proof it was
about 20 pages long
and was was some of the technical meat
of the paper
now in this new work just to offer some
comparison
we're actually able to prove a type
bound this is
theta of 2 to the n over 2 in the case
of
having only access to a classical memory
to perform the purity test on n qubits
and by contrast the most difficult part
of the proof which was previously 20
pages
using the learning tree technique is
just a half a page proof
in fact it's so straightforward that i'm
actually going to provide a brief sketch
of it on the next slide to show you
how it works
so let's look at a proof of the lower
bound for the purity
problem that i just mentioned using when
we have access to a classical memory
so as before let v not through vt minus
one be a root to leaf path through the
tree
now as we said the probability of taking
that path in the case that we are fed a
maxillary mix state
i'll call it p submixed which depends on
the path of the tree
which is simply this product it's the
same as the thing i showed you
is the equation i showed you on the
previous slide except that rho was
replaced here
by the maximum mixed state and the
result of this is just it's just a
constant it's just 1 over
2 to the nt now here
in the case that we have a heart random
pure state let psi be the har random
pure state and here we're taking the
expectation value over the hor ensemble
of states
and our goal is to bound the total
variational distance between these two
probability distributions
where again we we consider the total
variational distance here is just
essentially the one norm uh where we sum
over the absolute value of the
difference between these two probability
distributions
and sum over a root to leave paths
through the tree
so in other words we would like to show
that this quantity
uh is going to be uh is going to be
small namely that the two probabilities
distributions are close together if we
have a small number of rounds t
in particular that if if if big t the
number of rounds
that we only can start distinguishing
the two distributions using
our classical memory if we have an
exponentially large number of rounds
and as such have queried have gotten
exponentially many copies of the state
so let's write out this quantity here
let's just rewrite it up here
and we can do a simple manipulation
where we can rewrite it in the following
way
we can rewrite it we can remove the
absolute values in the factor of
half like this at the cost
of only summing over the root to leaf
paths
such that p mixed is greater than p pure
one can check this if this is an
unfamiliar identity by simply using the
fact
that the sum of p mixed equals 1 over
root leaf pass on the tree and similarly
for peep here
it basically just follows from that fact
if you unravel this identity
now let's factor out p mixed so we can
write as p this is simple algebraic
manipulation
p mix times 1 minus p pure over p mixed
and now if you would like to show that
this quantity is small
then what we would like to do is we
would like to show that this quantity is
very close to zero or is very very tiny
in particular if this quantity is tiny
if we neglect this term
then the sum over over root leaf paths
of p
mixed well this this is at most equal to
one since this is a normalized
probability distribution
so conceptually the thing we should do
is to show that this quantity is very
tiny
moreover we could simply it suffices to
show that this particular ratio is very
close to one
which would render this entire quantity
tiny and thus the entire sum
time so let's unpack the definition we
just simply look at the ratio of p
periodic mixed and this is what the
answer is
this is what this is equal to and um
here what we do when we perform the uh
the average the heart average
we have a combinatorial factor here and
we have a sum
um over permutations on t
elements where p sub pi is a
representation
of on permutations on t elements
where it permutes t copies of the
hilbert space
according in accordance with the
permutation pi
okay so this is what we get by just
doing the usual heart integral
and now we can observe we can use a
simple
estimate to bound this combinatorial
factor show that it is
lower bounded by 1 minus t over 2 to the
n to the t
power another estimate shows that this
is lower bounded by one
as such when you when you plug this when
you plug this back into this expression
we indeed find that this this quantity
is very very tiny
unless t is greater than or equal to
essentially two to the n over 2.
so this is the extent of the proof for
the exponential lower bound
and we can also match this with an upper
bound so that we actually get
theta of 2 to the n over 2. in other
words the protocol can be realized
but that's a separate proof now
with this in mind let's venture into
some new kinds of results
so let's talk first about exponential
separations in learning quantum states
along the lines of the purity tests that
i told you before
let's consider an interesting protocol
which i'll call for the purposes of this
talk the polystate property testing
suppose we're given a density matrix
which is the identity matrix plus p over
2 to the n
where p is a paulie string on n qubits
and our goal is to determine the pauli
string p
now a theorem from our paper is that
in the case of a quantum memory the the
number of queries which is required
is is order n in fact it's actually can
be realized in a gate efficient manner
and then the query complexity in the
case of the uh
of the classical memory is theta tilde
of two to the n
so up to log factors essentially it's
tight
now as i said the protocol of quantum
memory is gate efficient now what's
really interesting about this particular
protocol the sense in which it resolves
a conjecture in this paper with dorit
and xiao yang
is that this is a protocol which could
actually be realized on a contemporary
quantum computer
by contrast let's consider this poly
this this purity testing setting that i
just told you about
where we considered the difference
between a maximum mixed state and a har
random pure state
well you couldn't actually realize that
a contemporary quantum computer because
you can't actually prepare a har random
pure state
but this is a state that can be prepared
by a uh
by a low depth a constant depth circuit
and in fact this entire this protocol
the quantum memory
aspect of the protocol can actually be
realized in a gate efficient way on a
quantum computer
so the conjecture which it resolves is
that you can actually uh
there's a protocol for which there's an
exponential advantage between classical
and quantum memory for which the entire
protocol
including the state which is provided by
nature can all be
done on a contemporary quantum computer
now another result in is shadow
tomography without a quantum memory
the same of the problem is as follows
given a state row and observables one
through om
determine all the expectation values
trace of o i row
to epsilon error what we show is that in
the case where you only have a classical
memory
performing this shadow tomography
procedure on n qubits is theta tilde of
the minimum
of m and 2 to the n over epsilon squared
now the upper bound we in our paper july
derive the lower bound the upper bound
was from this paper
by huang kung preschool from earlier
this year
and this result actually resolves an
open problem uh that was
posed by aaron simon rothblum
now let me talk briefly about
exponential separations in learning
quantum channels instead of just
learning quantum states
in the case of quantum channels we have
this additional technical complication
that not only does nature so instead of
this case in which nature gives us a
state and we measure the state with a
povm
we have an additional flexibility of
first preparing
adaptively a state on which the channel
can act and then
to measure the result of that using a
povm namely we have the additional
flexibility to choose what the input
state is to the quantum channel which we
are attempting to learn
so let's consider the fixed unitary
problem which can be thought of as a
channel version of this purity problem
which i mentioned before
which the goal is to distinguish between
on the one hand the maximally
depolarizing channel
and on the other hand a fixed har random
unitary
now um an initial version of this result
was in this paper
uh with aharana than she but the result
was improved
um in an interesting way in this in this
work to appear with tran huang
li in which so the the complexity in the
case of a quantum memory
you just require order one queries and
in fact it's actually gate efficient
it's just order n
uh order and gate complexity and but the
interesting result is that the
complexity in the case of only having a
classical memory is lower bounded by an
exponential
so in particular in a way that i can
explain uh maybe in the in the questions
that people are interested is that
the results in this new paper both
generalizes the proof
and the uh and the uh and the setting of
the
of the paper from earlier this year as
well as improving the bound
it allows for more flexible types of
measurements to be made
uh which fully uh it allows for more
general adaptive strategies than were
considered in the earlier paper
and also gets a better bound and one
other problem to mention is what i will
call the symmetry distinction problem
now you can think about this as a toy
problem of an interesting question about
quantum many body systems
the quant a qua question in quantum many
body systems is determining say the
symmetry class of a quantum many-body
system
something that we're very interested in
doing in say condensed matter systems
a toy version of this is the following
suppose that
i have unitary evolution which is either
described by say a fixed heart
random unitary a fixed har random
orthogonal matrix
or a fixed har random um
[Music]
a fixed heart random symplectic matrix
now a unitary
an ordinary unitary an orthogonal matrix
and a symplectic matrix
all realize different manifestations of
time reversal symmetry
the first does not have time reversal
symmetry in the latter two do in two
different forms
in any case if you would like to
distinguish which of these three cases
is realized
that there is a lower bound or sorry
there there is uh
sorry this can be realized in the
quantum memory setting with order one
queries
namely you have to access you you query
that you applied the channel
order one times and it's actually also
gate efficient it's order
and gate complexity and in the case of
classical memory the query complexity is
lower bounded by an exponential
so the protocol as i said with the
quantum memory is gate efficient
and also the proof in the in the new
paper also generalizes the setting
of this earlier paper with dorito and
xiao yang in particular it allows for
more general kinds of adaptive
measurements to be performed
but still achieves an exponential lower
bound in the case of a classical memory
like to tell you about one last result
which is qualitatively different than
the ones that i've told you about before
you mean exponential separation with
bounded quantum memory
so let's consider shadow tomography with
bounded quantum memory
so this result as i said is
qualitatively different than the
previous ones
and let's assume that we have a quantum
memory but that it's bounded in size so
we're not going to consider a classical
memory we have a quantum memory but it's
only so large
now the theorem is as follows any
learning algorithm with k qubits of
quantum memory
requires um at least two to the n minus
k over three
copies of the state row to predict the
absolute value
of the expectation values of p rho for
all n cubed poly observables p
and succeeds with probability at least
two-thirds
in particular if you would like to learn
all of these expectation values in
absolute value
then if you only have k qubits of
quantum memory then you require
exponentially many copies of the state
exponential and the difference between n
and k
to successfully achieve this task
so this actually is interesting combines
all of the proof techniques of all of
the results previously mentioned
essentially and notice that it's quite
an interesting
lower bound because the lower bound is
only polynomial when n is x
when k is actually rather close to n
when when k goes like n minus
a coefficient times log of n is when
this becomes polynomial
so it's an interesting trade-off between
query complexity
and quantum memory now let me conclude
with a few remarks
and then i'll take questions so there's
the usual paradigm of quantum advantage
which is that quantum computers are
better than classical computers if doing
classical problems
now what's suggested by some of the
theorems and results that i've mentioned
in this talk
is a different kind of quantum advantage
which i might provisionally call
i'm not married to this name quantum
eidetic advantage
eidetic for instance coming from someone
with a perfect or lucid photographic
memory
quantum identity advantage the basic
idea is that quantum memory has an
advantage over classical memory for
performing quantum experiments
so what we've done in this talk is we've
developed
a new framework for proving exponential
separation between quantum learning
algorithms with and without a quantum
memory
we've also established the first
exponential tradeoff between bounded
quantum memory and query complexity that
was the last result that i mentioned
now a question is can we do is there is
it possible to do an experimental
demonstration of
quantum eidetic advantage or whatever
one may call it in the nisk era
a key question is what are the effects
of noise a lot of the exponential gaps
in query complexity
um will uh you you might worry that they
will be
they will dissolve in the presence of
noise because a lot of the
uh the exponential lower bounds are
based on doing swap tests which are not
so robust to noise
another question the final questions
were other physical examples along the
lines of this identity plus p over two
to the end task
this task was particularly interesting
because as i mentioned it was a task in
which every aspect of the task from the
preparation of the state
to the quantum memory protocol to
determine what the poly observable is
it could all be done in a contemporary
quantum computer so it would be
nice to have other examples along these
lines which could also be done
on quantum computers in the niskara with
that thank you so much for your
attention and happy to answer any
questions that people have
[Applause]
thanks for your time
one question in the last result uh in
the last resort with the shadow
tomography
it doesn't shadows mark we usually have
like if you
decide on a few uh observables in
advance
like you're saying you're saying all
polis uh right
yeah yeah yeah so for that one it's for
all polys i mean it would be interesting
to have a version of the results in
which um
so so in particular the uh
how do i say it's not gate efficient so
this is a statement about query
complexity because
we're trying to learn exponentially many
numbers but it would be interesting to
have a version of this separation in
which
you have a smaller set of observables
that you would like to learn so that
potentially that the protocol could
actually be
data efficient in some way
gate efficient when you have a quantum
memory which is large enough
anyway this word is i don't know how to
i don't at the moment know how to prove
a version of that problem in which you
have a much smaller set of observables
can you say again which result it's a
little hard to hear yeah this um
the result about the trade-off uh yeah
so then that is also some shadow
tomographic kind of task
yeah but this is this is like
this is not the classical tomography i
guess
no you've actually appointed them
but why is that necessary like can you
maybe shoot a light on like
where the quantum is memory or how does
it work
just uh roughly
yeah so um how do i say so
so one way of thinking okay so why would
we choose absolute value
i mean so i can provide a cert a few
pieces of intuition
so one of the things to say is that
while the different poly observables
well two poly observables don't commute
with one another
it is the case that if you look at
the second tensor power of poly
observables they do commute with each
other
so if you have two cop how do i say
um if you have that if you have the
ability to basically store for instance
two
you know uh if you have an n-qubit state
and you have access to being able to do
uh how do i say um if you have access to
source sort of two copies simultaneously
then it's very easy to achieve this task
because you would measure basically p
tensor p
with just the two copies of the state
but all the p tensor p's commute with
one another
that only allows you to learn
essentially the absolute value of the
traces of the polys against p
the trace of p against rho um it doesn't
allow you to know the sign
but the point is that that protocol
really requires you to have this sort of
commutativity really requires you to act
on two copies of the state
simultaneously
and so roughly the thing you might
imagine which is born out by the proof
is that there's an obstruction to having
too few qubits on which you can uh so
you know
if you don't basically have an
additional register of n qubits
then you can't do a protocol of the kind
that i just described
that it's obstructed somehow that's
that's where some intuition comes from
i'm not sure is that does that help a
bit or
yeah and then do you have some some
upper bounds where i don't know you you
you store
uh the first k qubits twice or something
so you can you get some advantage also
because it's only lower bound that you
show in this slide
um well i i don't know about this factor
of three but
uh i think that there should be there
may be ways of getting
i think this factor of three is not
tight but uh i think that there
um i think there is a way of probably
getting
an upper bound which is just not tight
to this one
i mean a lower bound i'm sorry yeah yeah
but but do you have an algorithm which
which say use is like 2 to the 2 and
minus k or something like that i don't
know
um not that i could uh tell you offhand
i'm not
i don't i don't know
thank you
oh so like in the symmetry distinction
problem can you say
anything about what the like what the
significance of those three types of
unitaries are
sure um let me go back to that so
okay so um here we go
so the short of it is that um
that okay so if you want to look at
symmetry classifications you can
consider anti-unitary symmetry you can
consider a time reversal operator
which is an operator which squares to
itself which is an anti-unitary
transformation
and essentially there are
three ways in which the uh
or how do i say
essentially there's okay well there's
different ways of answering the question
but there is a classification
essentially of symmetries of time
reversal symmetries that was due to
dyson
in the context of unitaries and these
different
symmetry classes unitary orthogonal and
symplectic
realize the three forms of time reversal
symmetry that that you were allowed
uh with certain assumptions uh for
example i mean
it is it depends on certain structures
of your hilbert space like having an
inner product
if you also imagine that you have
systems with fermions there's a ten-fold
classification instead of a three-fold
classification
but this is basically just these are
representative
symmetry classes uh for time reversal
symmetry or so
these are these are representative
unitaries of three-time reversal
symmetry classes
namely this one does not have time
reversal symmetry orthogonal does
and symplectic also does i'm not sure if
they answer your question it's a bit of
a longer story
that i uh maybe
talk about offline these um is it short
of it that these um
unitary classes or like okay is it short
of it that these symmetries
in these unitary classes are just
studied for
reasons in many body physics
that was the last session for today so
see everyone tomorrow at 9am